a major fire in a busy Market about to
get much worse
the building locals say had been used to
store fireworks
[Music]
on a clear sunny day this plume of smoke
was visible Across The Armenian capital
emergency crews were soon battling to
extinguish the flames
volunteers using debris to clear more of
it from the site
survivors carefully brought to safety
like fireworks and smoke everything
shattered in a second there are
warehouses technical rooms it's like
fireworks fireworks fireworks everything
happened in one minute people could not
get out of the stores
the mayor's office in Yerevan said an
unknown number of people had been left
trapped under the rubble the sheer scale
of This Disaster becoming clear to all
as desperate rescue efforts continued
it's been utter shock this is the first
time in In My Memory that such an
explosion such a tragedy has happened in
the capital city
um everybody is glued to social media
networks and to the news to try and find
out what's happening
Rescuers have been hampered by more
firework explosions as Crews tried to
make the area safe
by late afternoon heavy Vehicles were
clearing parts of the blast zone while
elsewhere Rescuers were using their
hands to search for anyone trapped and
still alive
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera